some movie scenes are so hilarious
exciting a romantic that we go back to
watch them again and again and never get
tired of them then there are the other
ones the unsettling moments and creepy
scenes that stick with us even if we
only watch them once here are just a few
of the uncomfortable movie scenes that
will never ever watch again in the nice
guys Island March is the worst detective
in Los Angeles maybe even the world
it's just Fred's never been gone this
long before how long has he been missing
since the funeral played by a hilarious
Ryan Gosling March is a bumbling
alcoholic who's hired to find a missing
adult film star his quest is filled with
all sorts of injuries both to his pride
and his well-being but the most painful
moment comes when he accidentally slits
his wrists at one point March tries the
old p.i trick of just wrapping up his
hand punching through a small pane of
glass and reaching inside to unlock the
door
but March is no action hero needless to
say he immediately regrets it granted
the scene is played for laughs and
Gosling does an amazing job selling the
comedy
that's what but seeing and hearing all
that blood leaves us feeling queasy and
that definitely isn't nice guys with a
title like creep it should come as no
surprise that this horror flick is one
uncomfortable experience the film
follows an unlucky cameraman named Aaron
who's hired to make a video for a weirdo
named Joseph who claims he's dying of
cancer and wants to make a film for his
unborn child but this seemingly sweet
idea gets freakier and freakier as
Joseph abandons Aaron in the woods tells
him a disturbing tale about his marriage
and performs a song and dance number
while wearing a wolf mask at the end of
the day it's gonna be normal so this
trust me that's not gonna be anything
weird at all but all that comes after
Joseph's first bit of creepiness early
in the film he tells Aaron to follow him
into the bathroom for tubby time when
Joseph was a little kid he would take
baths with his dad since he won't be
around to share this with his son Joseph
wants to recreate that experience on
film and yeah watching from Aaron's
perspective is Joseph strips down and
starts playing with an imaginary baby
and the bathtub is about as awkward and
unsettling as it sounds
then it gets weirder one moment Joseph
is playing with his imaginary kid and
the next he sinks into a depression
starts talking about suicide and slides
under the water like he plans to drown
himself when Aaron leans over the tub to
check on Joseph and the mad man comes
screaming at the camera it's quite the
jump scare and perfectly sets the mood
for all the creepiness to come steve
carell is no stranger to cringe-worthy
moments but a lot of fun talk about
prison today but I am here to scare you
straight but after leaving the office he
wound up in more awkward situations in
Foxcatcher
this film based on a tragic true story
finds Carell playing John du Pont an
eccentric millionaire with a fondness
for firearms cocaine and combat sports
even though he's incredibly rich DuPont
is still desperate to win the approval
of his mother a cold woman more fond of
her prize-winning horses than her own
son searching for just a tiny bit of
praise DuPont starts a wrestling team in
hopes of winning some Olympic gold even
though he's just a novice when it comes
to the sport he takes control of the
class from coach Dave Schultz played by
Mark Ruffalo and starts giving an
inspirational speech to the athletes
about representing America and becoming
winners in life things get especially
Prynne gee when he calls one of the
wrestlers on to the mat and demonstrates
some incredibly basic techniques in an
attempt to impress his mom eventually du
pot winds up on the ground with a guy on
his back and that's when his mom leaves
with a disapproving scowl the look on du
Pont's face is heartbreaking and even
though he's a manipulative psycho
watching this man humiliate himself will
make you wrestle with some complicated
feelings I don't like the sport of
wrestling as you know it's a low sport
even by the standards of Quentin
Tarantino the hateful eight is full of
mean disgusting moments that will make
you squirm
seat in fact it might have the single
grossest seen that Tarantino has ever
put to film the poisoned coffee sequence
the hateful eight finds a bunch of
killers trapped inside a cabin as a
blizzard rages outside
among these Shootist and scoundrels
we've got John Ruth a bounty hunter
handcuffed a notorious murderer Daisy
too murky Oh Ruth knows that Daisy has
an Inside Man in the cabin who wants to
kill him and set his outlaw boss free
but Ruth never suspects that the
mysterious mole would go so far as to
poison his coffee after he takes a swig
from his mug he immediately starts
vomiting what we can only call
extra-chunky blood really nobody got a
problem with that kicks off a chain
reaction in the film and maybe even the
audience and by the end of it Ruth is
dead and we're looking sideways at
Starbucks for the rest of our lives you
got anything in here besides coffee that
can help warm us up the bum is open Phil
my anihilation isn't what you'd call a
feel-good flick directed by Alex garland
this sci-fi movie deals with some heavy
themes like regrets infidelity and
depression on top of all that you've got
the shimmer an alien electromagnetic
field that mixes and matches the DNA of
any living creature that steps inside
its translucent walls as a result were
treated to a nightmare world where
deformed animals scream like human
beings alligator sharks grow to enormous
size and Tessa Thompson turns into a
tree but the most horrific image inside
the shimmer comes when our heroes
discover an old video camera that
reveals the fate of an earlier
expedition when they play the footage we
see a wild-eyed soldier played by Oscar
Isaac performing some amateur surgery on
one of his comrades that's bad enough by
itself but then we see why thanks to the
shimmers gene-splicing abilities this
guy's intestines have come to life and
they're oozing around like some giant
worm it's a scene that starts off
sadistic before taking a turn into
lovecraft territory and no matter how
hard you try you'll never be able to
annihilate this moment from your memory
the King of Comedy was the fourth
collaboration between Robert De Niro and
Martin Scorsese and while it's not as
well-known as taxi driver or Raging Bull
it's definitely the most awkward movie
they've ever made a black comedy about
the dark side of show business the film
finds De Niro as Rupert Pupkin a wannabe
comedian who idolizes late-night
talk-show host Jerry Langford played by
Jerry Lewis Rupert thinks if he could
just get on Jerry's show and perform his
set then he could make it into the big
time however Rupert is a delusional
creep who fantasizes about being Jerry's
best friend eventually the fantasy
spills over into reality when Rupert
starts stalking Jerry and even shows up
at Jerry's mansion completely uninvited
making things worse Rupert has brought
along a date who has no idea that her
psycho boyfriend isn't really friends
with the talk-show host
slowly but surely Rupert state realizes
they're not supposed to be in this man's
house and we can totally feel this poor
woman's embarrassment but Rupert just
keeps on pretending that he's Jerry's
best friend the whole scene is
shudderingly awkward and it feels so
genuinely raw and confrontational
because the actors were improvising all
their lines Darren Aronofsky's requiem
for a dream might be the most traumatic
film of all time and probably the
greatest anti-drug PSA ever made every
moment with Ellen Burstyn is Sara
Goldfarb is just heartbreaking all
building up to the infamous climax where
our four main characters experience what
it must be like to visit hell if we had
to pick one element of the film that
absolutely forces viewers to look away
and discuss though it could be any scene
involving Jared Leto's arm
just killing me sanika Leto plays Harry
Goldfarb a heroin addict whose
intravenous drug use causes a pain in
one of his arms to become horribly
infected and one of the saddest moments
of the film the arm grows so disgusting
that its amputated during an operation
but before that awful moment we witness
a jittery Harry prepare to shoot up by
sticking the needle in his swollen black
arm the injection site is oozing with
dark liquid but Harry jabs that needle
into the vein anyway causing moviegoers
everywhere to say no to drugs the square
is an award-winning satire of the
contemporary art world but it also
contains an infamously show-stopping
sequence the monkey man scene it happens
at a prestigious dinner party where a
muscle-bound artist storms into a
roomful of wealthy patrons this guy is
hunched over with stilts attached to his
arms and he's howling like an ape he's a
performance artist pretending to be a
chimpanzee and at first it seems like
fun and games he waddles around the room
grunts and amuses the patrons with his
eerily accurate chimp impression but
just like real chimps the artist gets
ultra aggressive incredibly fast
stalking around the room and harassing
guests the terrified patrons keep
perfectly quiet and still but things
finally go way too far when he leaps on
a table and assaults a female patron
prompting everyone in the room to beat
him to a pulp this insane performance
goes on for around 12 minutes and
perhaps it feels so real because notary
actually picked on extras he sensed were
nervous whenever he walked by don't
worry too much though the woman he
attacked was played by a stunt person
who was aware of and ready for the scene
the final product is unbearably tense
and amazingly uncomfortable and just
like the horror struck patrons we don't
want to revisit this terrifying
experience again tusk is not a great
movie it bombed at the box office that
offended critics and it features one of
Johnny Depp's worst performances which
is saying something there are however a
couple of killer scenes and perhaps the
most horrifically uncomfortable moment
comes when podcaster wallace bryton
played by justin long realizes he's
missing a pretty important body part
after meeting an eccentric adventurer
called Howard
while looking for a good story for a
show Wallace drinks some spiked tea and
wakes up later in a wheelchair heavily
anesthetized than - a lay still under
the effects of Howard spike T Wallace
freaks out when he sees his stitched up
stump and Howard explains that a doctor
had to amputate the limb after Wallace
was bitten by a brown recluse but as
tears well up in Wallace's eyes Howard
is trying to hold back laughter after
all he's the one who cut the leg off as
part of a twisted experiment tusk is a
little tough to watch for a lot of
reasons but in this case it's on purpose
from its 2001 a Space Odyssey style
opening to its fiery finale
everything about 2013's under the skin
is eerie even though this film has dudes
getting sucked out of their skin however
the most unsettling moment has got to be
that awful beach scene Scarlett
Johansson plays an extraterrestrial
being who lures men to their deaths
usually by driving around in a van
picking up guys and taking them back to
her apartment where they meet a fate
worse than death in this particular
scene though Johansson is hunting for
prey at a Scottish beach where she
witnesses a woman getting pulled out
into the sea she dispassionately watches
the woman disappear into the waves and
she doesn't move to help when the
woman's lover drowns trying to save her
in fact she only reacts after a would-be
hero tries in vain to save the couple
and has washed ashore unconscious she
drags the man to her van intent on
killing him and completely ignores the
drowned couples abandoned baby crying in
terror on the beach Johansson's
character never feels more inhuman and
predatory than she does here and her
cruel indifference leaves a sick cold
feeling in our stomachs check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]